من جديد ما تزال فرق الدفاع المدني
والمدنيون المتطوعون معها يحاولون انتشال
بعض العالقين تحت الانقاص في كل من سرمدا
وجنديرس والاقارب التي لم تنتهي عمليات
البحث فيها حتى هذه اللحظه منذ ساعات
الصباح فيما تستمر المناشدات في كل من
سلقين لتوجه الاليات من اجل انتشار بعض
العوائل من تحت الانقاض خصوصا نحن نعتمد
على بلاغات المدنيين الذين المتواجدين في
المناطق التي تضررت من الزلزال في عمق
الاراضي السوريه ان كان من جبل الزاويه
وغصوا الى المنطقه الى ريف حلب الشرقي
وسويلاريف ادلب الغربي هذه المناطق كلها
اتضررت من الزلزال السرق الاسعاف تعتمد
ايضا على الكوادر المدنيه والسيارات
المدنيين في نقل على المصابين وذلك بسبب
نقص في سيارات الاسعاف من الوقت سابق جراء
المكان عمليات الاستهداف المباشر من اثناء
الحرب او حتى
تعطل هذه السيارات بوقت سابق ولم يتم
اصلاحها بس
منذ ساعات الصباح المبكر وهذه هي المره
الاولى التي يستهدف هكذا زلزال المنطقه
منذ زمن بعيد لذلك هناك نقص في الخبره
بالتعامل مع هكذا وضع
يعتمد المدنيون على النداءات والتوجيهات
التي تطلقها كل من الدفاع المدني
والمنظمات المحليه طيب اضافه الى السلطات
الحكوميه الموجوده او اتحدث عن الحكومه
المؤقته والسلطات الموجوده التي تحاول
الارشاد المدنيين للابتعاد عن التجمعات
السكنيه المهترئه التي لم تخضع الى
الصيانه منذ وقت طويل